sometimes i wonder if this heart is in
it
so much like your father
the fondness in her face
it's like she wants to see anakin again
yeah seeing that in that creepy cgi face
there's an affection there of an old
friend lost
you know for a minute i forgot about
that
now
are you getting some like romantic vibes
from luke here like yeah
the way she looked at him she was like
there's a lot
there's a lot about your father i miss
may the force be with you
and when will we see ahsoka again
sooner or later eventually because
there's money to be made that's right
get that money honey welcome back to new
rockstars while we wait for obi-wan
kenobi to premiere production for ahsoka
it's currently underway setting up star
wars celebration at the end of may that
will likely drop major reveals about
obi-wan and ahsoka as well as andor
mandalorian season three maybe even star
wars movies being a thing again but
across all of these titles is certain to
be a live-action reunion between ahsoka
and anakin skywalker with rosario dawson
hayden christensen sharing the screen
together what's that going to look like
and will we have to wait for the ahsoka
series to revisit those clone wars era
flashbacks or could we see ahsoka again
as soon as
this is wikileaks it's our weekly
reaction to the latest in star wars i'm
here with tommy bechtold tommy how you
doing
baby so good the force is strong with me
this week the force is powerful with me
this week celebration at the end of may
can't come soon enough i don't know if
i'm going sometimes i go sometimes i
don't it's probably sold out where is it
this year anaheim
anaheim i may be wrong anaheim nice i
went to it in london once and let me
tell you
it was a lot of fun it was crazy i got
to see anthony daniels carrie fisher
wow mark hamill was there it was oh it
was unbelievable that's really cool i
hope
this year's celebration
will give us much cause to celebrate on
this show because it'll be littered with
news
juicy news items i'm super pumped
honestly for this like
maybe we'll finally get some information
about when rogue squadron is dropping
she and carlo esposito while promoting
better call saul this week said that we
might even see mandalorian season three
this summer which should be crazy
because bad batch is coming in august
so
when this summer when we would we see it
i maybe he means like a trailer this
summer i guess we'll find out um or
maybe he's wrong he doesn't know he's
not in the editing booth for that show
he's got a dozen projects he's working
on i mean he might be he's a really
talented person he is who am i to say
this guy could be he's like
here and cut there yeah uh yes um export
now oh we rendered the wrong he just
refers he just refers to every editor as
mr white in a really menacing tone all
right mr white do exactly as i tell you
and while we're in uh eric and tommy's
uh we're actually human beings corner
here uh i just want to thank everyone in
the bay area for coming to see my uh
first improv show in like two years at
in games improv stage works theater in
the mission that was so kind of you i
did not think we would get that big of a
turnout but you guys showed up in full
force and were so sweet afterwards it
was such a pleasure meeting all of you
by the way i think my first show is
going to be may 14th that's a saturday
at 9 00 pm uh first show with the new
cast called uh well for here censored
your f'd up relationship it's kind of
like their marquis show i'm so excited
to be joining that group i think you
will all love it well they're lucky to
have you eric i'm lucky to have them to
be honest these folks are so funny like
we'll have to get the southern office up
north for or up central california for
for a viewing of your show one of these
days uh in our bay
in our band
we're gonna go to the bay we own the
bay no one owns the bay maybe elon does
but he's spending his money on twitter
so he owns twitter now yeah
yeah anyway let's dive into ahsoka so
ahsoka tano has shared many moments with
her former master over the years
throughout the clone wars locking sabers
with him as darth vader during the
rebels era as we saw in one of the best
episodes of that series but today we're
going to talk about where we will see
ahsoka in live action next what new
elements of her relationship with anakin
will be revealed
throughout these upcoming titles before
we get into that though time is running
out to grab yourself the moon knight
latest obsession shirt from new rock
stars is called tomb of the moon god and
buying it not only directly supports us
here at new rock stars but it also
unlocks the ability to get a special
shout out in our weekly inside marvel
after shows for moon night so you gotta
get it before it sells out over at
newrockstarsmerch.com
all right tommy our big ahsoka question
this week what is it you know what i'm
gonna go throw back every once in a
while a question uh comes along on this
show that makes me go back to the book
of boba fett and i like to just frame it
under those questions the way we used to
ask that so i'm gonna ask you today eric
when the fat will we see ahsoka and
anakin together in live action
great question tommy and i love how we
asked what the fed when like the the
biggest
implication episodes of that had didn't
really have anything to do with boba
fett but no we're gonna ask it because
we don't yeah
uh that's right it's fun to ask at that
that's fun to say and it's fun to hear
it feels naughty but it's not
well obi-wan kenobi's first two episodes
are dropping on may 27th and with hayden
christensen returning to play darth
vader on the series we have wondered why
they're bringing back the actor to play
the character in the era when he's
almost always seen in his mask unless
the kenobi series will flash back to
anakin's clone wars days the time when
he spent many of those days with ahsoka
tano uh
now uh we know for sure that rosario
dawson hayden christensen will appear in
at least one star wars series together
because production for ahsoka is
scheduled to really uh kick into gear
this month there are reports that peter
ramsey is going to be directing one of
these episodes and they've started to
announce the cast i don't think this has
been officially confirmed but it sounds
like we're going to have along with
rosario dawson
a cast that also includes mary elizabeth
winstead hayden christensen reprising
his role as anakin skywalker on the
ahsoka series uh natasha leo bordizzo as
sabine wren and ukrainian actress ivana
sachno and then ray stevenson who's
reportedly playing the villain now you
may remember ray stevenson voice gar
saxon on rebels in clone wars gar saxon
being the mandalorian commander of
maul's shadow collective later served as
the governor of mandalore during the
empire reign and sort of the emperor's
hand now gar saxon died in the year 2bb
why a duel with sabine ran on cronus uh
you know that character died but
stevenson could play him in flashback or
he could play his brother tiger saxon
who came back in the next season of
rebels or he could play in the way that
like john favreau voiced pre-visla as
well as paz vizsla uh he could play um
stevenson could play one of the
descendants so like everyone in house
saxon his voice by this actor i guess
we'll see i mean it just as easily could
just flash back to the clone wars era
it'd just be interesting because they've
also said that this show is going to be
in the mandalorian timeline which be you
know years
decades maybe in some case after
uh oh no it would just be like what 15
years or so after the rebels era but but
still that also poses like this
weirdness for rosario dawson if she's
gonna be playing like her younger self
or if they'll bring in a younger actor
to play her but at the time of the end
of the clone wars and and certainly
during the rebels era
she was already an adult so just be like
an adult who's like 15 years younger
than rosario dawson is so it was yeah
but she's pretty ageless so i don't know
she's pretty ageless she she looks well
younger than her years and especially
they have her in her uh togretta uh
head piece like they could certainly get
away with it i think now actually a few
months back a rumored production listing
came out the plot summary for ahsoka it
said it's a star wars spin-off series
set within the timeline of the
mandalorian so they said that uh they
say ahsoka tano as it took her to female
who was the padawan learner to anakin
skywalker and a hero of the clone wars
alongside anakin she grew from
headstrong student into a mature leader
but her destiny laid along a different
path in the jedi ahsoka is on the hunt
for the evil grand admiral thrawn in the
hope that it will help her locate the
missing ezra bridger the young jedi that
disappeared with thrawn many years ago
and they say that season three the
mandalorian wraps march 23rd 2022 now
that was back before
you know they didn't know when exactly
they're gonna start shooting now um
sounds like thrawn is gonna be the
villain of this series so i don't know
if ray stevenson is gonna be playing
thrawn i think he's just gonna be
playing you know a member of house saxon
maybe someone who serves thrawn is what
that means and they haven't announced
yet who thrawn is gonna be played by
although who knows like lucasfilm loves
to reuse voice actors and cast them in
different roles it's just in this case i
i i don't know if like a lot of people
are pushing that um they wanted to see
uh lars mickelson do thrawn uh a lot of
people push her up into the cover match
i think he'd be a great thrawn i just i
i i i don't need to see him as major
roles in multiple things right
yeah spread the love spread the love now
uh if we have to wait for ahsoka to
reunite with anakin in the ahsoka series
and it's probably going to be a clone
wars flashback since obviously in the
mandalorian timeline after the galactics
of war of darth vader's dead but if
rosario dawson shows up in kenobi we
actually have some other options because
you know one could just be also a clone
wars flashback but another could be a
moment maybe in which ahsoka and vader
either cross paths or nearly come to
crossing paths during the same time as
obi-wan kenobi's looking after luke
which would be the era in ahsoka's
history where she was a fulcrum agent in
the you know for the rebels where she
was sharing some intel we learned about
uh the way this started in the ahsoka
novel uh and it explores her journey
from the end of the clone wars uh to
when she reappears and rebels how at uh
bail organa's request she adopts that
role as the rebel agent the spy fulcrum
sending this coded intel to the
separated and scattered rebel factions
but around the time of kenobi and nine
bby that would be about four years
before ahsoka reappears uh in the
animated series rebels and we don't know
a ton about where ahsoka was exactly
during those years so there's kind of
this gap period where they can fill it
in with more stories if they want to now
the season two finale of rebels shows
vader reuniting with ahsoka on malachor
that was when ezra and kanan and soko
were were ended up in this inquisitor
trap
and they run into mall it's such a crazy
two-part episode uh but i love it they
they end up having to steal this
holocron from the sith temple uh vader
uh runs back into ahsoka it's such a
dramatic moment now this is before we
saw
clone wars season seven so we didn't
know how they were gonna wrap up their
story we just knew that like they had
clone wars season five that ended with
like
you know uh ahsoka parting ways of the
jedi temple and then you had these
season six episodes that were kind of
these unfinished arcs uh that didn't
really explore what happened to ahsoka
after that so uh this was like the next
moment we were so excited to see these
two again and uh vader's like it was
we're told that you would be here and
ahsoka told him that like oh you you
killed my friend anakin you killed that
anakin identity well i will avenge him
and then he's like revenge on the jedi
way and she's like i am no jedi and it
was so cool so cool that it was a little
weird later to see her in the
mandalorian where the episode was called
the jedi but maybe it's referring to
not her we don't really know maybe
that's just a question of what it means
to be a jedi um but this fight is
awesome she cuts open vader's mask and
he she hears his voice and he's like
ahsoka in a moment those two eye to eye
reconnected and she's like i won't leave
you not this time and he's like then you
will die and then they they lock blades
again
the episode ends with him like stumbling
away from the battle they're separated
but like her her bird her bird is there
and flies into the smoke uh so they're
both there it's just a heartbreaking
reunion so
we
i won't leave you not like last time
could refer
to a lot of things because like it's i
don't know watching that final season of
clone wars i don't really know what this
moment was where she left him i think
the writing of that moment referred to
how she left the jedi order at the end
of clone wars season five you know like
she turned her back on him but like
there were other moments between them
after that uh that was filled in by the
final season of clone wars so i want to
know like could there be another moment
where these two cross paths uh they
could certainly fill that in if they're
doing this with obi-wan kenobi uh a this
little duel between them we didn't know
existed there could be another moment
between ahsoka invader and that could
explain how ahsoka knew that it was
anakin under the vader helmet because
not everyone in the star wars universe
realizes that they're the same person
like a lot of people think that anakin
skywalker died
yeah he's actually dead right so for
ahsoka to know that now you could say
through the force through her
connections with bail organa and yoda
there's there's all kinds of ways that
she could know this but i think there's
there's just a little moment where you
could see that realization to be a fun
thing to explore in live action so tommy
i've been talking a long time i want to
know from you which vader and ahsoka
encounter do you think would be more
powerful to see in live action a duel
during the galactic civil war when
ahsoka was fulcrum or a flashback to
their friendlier clone wars adventures
and no vader mask at all
i you know i think
a duel is going to be more exciting to
see on screen right like a flashback
will be
we could maybe it might trigger an
emotional reaction from the viewers but
like watching them go at it although we
did already have that great duel between
them so it's kind of maybe a little
anticlimactic to have them fight again
i
i would say you know
the most
the thing i would actually look the most
forward to would be
in the band if they for them to meet
with anakin as a force ghost in the
mandalorian timeline you know what i
mean like to like have anakin return and
kind of have them almost make amends i
know i just said that that wouldn't be
as exciting but like i would genuinely
enjoy hating christensen
uh you know as anakin like being like
maybe ahsoka is finding her faith tested
again and finding her resolution tested
again and he feels that compelled to
appear before her and be like i have
made every mistake you could possibly
make in this path don't go down don't
let your anger consume you you know that
type of thing but if we're going just
for a straight answer to the question
you asked i want to see him lock swords
i want to see him lock lightsabers i
don't know i want to see him fight i
don't want to see her cut the mask again
i want him to threaten each other and
then you know i want
i want neither of them to die because i
don't want anyone to ever die i want
everyone to live forever and and the
whole galaxy to be overcrowded with life
beings uh just uh eating and crapping
everywhere
and that's when you need a thanos
i think yeah uh
you brought up that's why they call me
the reverse thanos
you brought up an interesting
distinction uh tommy between like what
would be more exciting
to me i think with when it comes to
hayden christmas and rosario dawson and
these characters that they're playing i
don't need exciting i think i need
impactful i think i need catharsis i
think i need
a conversation to happen um and i think
there are plenty of other places for
thrilling sword fights to happen um
between the inquisitors and and these
other characters that's where like the
flashing blades is gonna be more fun um
but between these two
like i i kind of want uh i want
this show or all of these shows to give
hayden christiansen the opportunity to
show that he actually is a much better
actor than he was given credit for in
those prequels uh and rosaria dawson's a
very good actor
what if she shows up in kenobi
and the inquisitor is about to like
strike her and vader goes like
it stops he like has a momentary lapse
in conscious and like stops the
inquisitor from like killing her yeah
and then
and then immediately is like no i'm not
fatal now i have to i should kill her
put me in my back attack ah don't look
at me
short circuiting from his human tears
going into his robot body
that's exactly what's going to happen i
mean that'd be fascinating would vader
turn on an inquisitor to to save a
soaker to spare ahsoka yeah or would
anakin
anakin pulling the last little anakin
nest invader uh
and showing a little and a kindness if
you will and a kindness i think put it
on a shirt epic hero
slap that [ __ ]
random acts of and a kindness
i think that um if that happens in
obi-wan kenobi that'd be such a powerful
moment between vader and ahsoka that i'd
be like why is this show called obi-wan
kenobi why do they title any of these
shows why don't they just call it star
wars i know i just you know me i can't
help but write a little fan fiction but
no i want to see it i think set up that
moment to happen and then we could see
it in a flashback in the ahsoka series
you know i think i i'd love to see
ahsoka show up in kenobi just to kind of
set up that there's more to learn about
their relationship from whatever era
just pepper her in she's great like
she's getting her own show but we want
to see her in everything because we like
her character yeah and i like rosario
dawson so now tommy and i are going to
talk about uh have a little debate on
what might be the most overrated and
most underrated star wars title we're
going to talk about that in just a
minute but before we do that we want to
thank some friends who helped us make
this episode thank you to me undies for
sponsoring this episode of wikileaks our
friends at myundes have a new star wars
collaboration that we're so excited
about here at wikileaks they're back
with two new limited edition prints
lightspeed and rebel squadron you can
get a matching pair for your favorite
person or you can fly solo and just get
a pair for yourself you can get these
prints in socks loungewear dog hoodies
and all matter of underwear from boxers
to briefs to boxer briefs and in sizes
from extra small to 4xl they've got
other great collaborations available
from the simpsons game of thrones batman
and other properties or just get some
black and white ones if you're not into
the fancy patterns but just want to
enjoy their insanely comfortable undies
truly me undies are the most comfortable
in the world these bad boys will live at
the top of your stack of clean clothes
because they'll be the first ones you
want to put on meondas has a great offer
for my listeners for any first-time
purchasers you get 15 off and undies
shipped right to your door to get 15 off
your first order and 100 satisfaction
guarantee go to meundies.com wookie
w-o-o-k-i-e just one e in this code
that's meundies.com wookie eric you know
me i never ask for uh for anything from
our sponsors except for blue chew which
i need for medical reasons it keeps my
heart beating but i gotta get some of
those rogue squadron me undies if you're
listening me undies i'll i'll model them
on instagram for you uh tommy you
uh taking bluetooth gets my heart
pumping right
that's the only thing
all right the only thing that works for
me
is you taking bluetooth
oh that's why we get along so well
we're links they are a dyad we are tired
all right we also want to thank raycon
for sponsoring this episode if you're
looking to shake things up this year
maybe exercise more maybe get out of the
house more there's no better way to do
it than with a pair of raycon wireless
earbuds in your ears raycon wireless
earbuds are the best way to bring audio
with you because no matter how much you
shake things up literally no matter how
much you shake you know that they will
not fall out of your ears their everyday
earbuds look feel and sound better than
ever there's also awareness mode for
when you need to listen to your
surroundings so that you can take
break-ons with you wherever you go with
optimized gel tips for the perfect
in-ear fit these earbuds are so
comfortable and they will not budge
there's nothing worse than being really
into a song or a podcast and it just
cuts out at the worst moment because
your earbud just fell out well with
raycon so you don't have to worry about
that raycons offer 8 hours of play time
and a 32 hour battery life and they're
priced just right you get quality audio
at half the price of other premium audio
brands raycon's everyday earbuds have
over 48 000 5 star reviews right now the
wikileaks audience can get 15 off their
raikon order at buy raycon dot com slash
wookie that's buy raycon dot com slash
wookie with two e's to save 15 off on
raycon's by raycon dot com slash wookie
uh all right tommy so this week or last
week really the director of guardians of
the galaxy the suicide squad peacemaker
james gunn tweeted quote i don't know
why rogue one is trending but i'm glad
it is as it's the most underrated star
wars anything uh and i love that he said
that because i love rogue one i do
believe it is underrated though
like all star wars titles it has found
more love in more in recent years after
like rizzo skywalker's come out everyone
has gone back to rogue one and said this
movie is actually amazing
so i don't know if it is truly
underrated anymore but from james gunn's
point of view it certainly is and i
think to a lot of people's point of view
it might be the most underrated but i
wanted us to talk about this tommy i
want us to make a case for what we think
is the most underrated and the most
overrated star wars title you want to go
first
uh well i you know if we're talking
about underrated first i mean it has
become in later years the most beloved
of the prequels but revenge of the sith
i think objectively is a good movie and
i think it got lumped in
in the fun of mocking the prequels at
the time and just in general the age
that like
if you think about the timeline of it
the people that saw the new trilogy as
children as like age 7 to 15 were
becoming like 35 to 40 year olds when
the prequels came out and like just
mastering the internet like you know
like just they were they were like in
that generation of texas people and they
just tore it apart online and i
i think revenge of the sith is
objectively from start to finish a
pretty good movie and has a very
exciting conclusion that is upsetting
and you know like sk like it it it
adequately and satisfyingly explains
anakin's transformation into darth vader
and and it's
hard to watch if you're a fan and you
know luke and leia if you're like you
know if you love the original movies and
you see you know who luke and leia are
you're like oh god this man is it could
have been their father like you know
it's hard not to like humanize it and
put it on earth you know and in earthly
familial relations
relationships as you know as it were but
uh so i don't i mean i think that that's
always one that is is underrated agreed
you know i'm trying to think of a more
like sexy pic there were parts i mean i
felt like solo because of the director
change got really unfairly maligned and
kind of got the treatment of like this
movie is going to suck no matter what i
don't think it ever got a fair chance to
be properly rated but there were a lot
of things about that movie that i
enjoyed as well and a lot of characters
introduced that i enjoyed but uh
you know so i guess i'll just throw that
one in there as a rogue underrated i
think um i think you make some good
points tommy i agree i think revenge of
the sith is is really great definitely
the the best of the prequels and i think
all the prequels over the years have
been
unfairly maligned and maybe unfairly
praised i think people thanks to clone
wars kind of just like overlook some of
the glaring plot issues of it like
filled in some great it did like some
great uh remodeling work to the overall
uh prequels mansion like they brought in
a master contractor with the animated
shows right and that's exactly and i
think that kind of skews a lot of
people's perceptions of the franchise as
a whole like they don't necessarily
judge the movie as it was the the two to
two and a half hour experience they
judge the way they feel about these
characters in this era which is totally
fine i'd much rather people have
positive opinion opinions and positive
associations with these things because
there's so much craft that goes into
them so why not i will never fault
anyone for having a positive opinion
about the prequels uh or any era of star
wars so that leads me to my pick for
what i think might be the most
underrated because i i don't think i've
heard anyone on twitter say anything
nice about this movie uh in a while and
maybe we're just in this cycle of the
backlash versus the backlash to the
backlash to the backlash but i'm gonna
for my underrated pick i think rogue one
is properly rated right now i think most
of the movies pre-2016 are like properly
properly rated i think i'm gonna say
most underrated
hot take rise to skywalker episode
now no i do not think this is a great
movie by any means i don't want anyone
to think i'm i'm uh uh praising this
movie or putting on any pedestal i
understand it is a flawed movie with
many many problems and but i think it is
maligned because it is emblematic of
many people's problems with the sequel
trilogy that are not necessarily this
movie's fault now you could blame uh jj
abrams for them but
jj abrams he has said that he had some
pitches he had some concept art of a
different movie so i don't know who he
can really blame i don't know if he
could blame kathleen kennedy or george
lucas or anyone at disney or lucasfilm
for this like this is just they gave
what they thought audiences wanted uh
and it was a mess the lines like
palpatine returned somehow uh clone and
we're ridiculous uh the fact that
palpatine returned it all is insane
however i believe this is a beautiful
film to look at and has some of the most
gorgeous production design and has some
truly beautiful moments between
characters uh what the way they
resurrected carrie fisher visually on
screen i'm not a fan of uh but they were
able to achieve some beautiful moments
of catharsis between these characters
that i did not think they would ever be
able to do hexagonal is one of my
favorite star wars locations the sith
temple looks terrifying the way they
made palpatine look in that movie was
chilling and i think a lot of people
were like well it's star wars they're
always going to look pretty but that's
not a big deal it's like it is a big
deal when a movie is a big deal oh my
god that's like hard to do that's like
assuming if you never clean your house
and it's a three million dollar you know
california mcmansion if you never clean
it never tend the garden well it's a
three million dollar house it's always
going to look awesome so yeah no no no
no no no you have to work on it to make
it look good still right so i i
movie i just think people say that
there's nothing good about that movie
and i think people just pile all their
hate on it and i just don't agree with
that i think there's a lot of crap that
went into it i can go on all of those
journeys with you and agree the only
thing that was unforgivable to for me
and i'm so glad that it happened but i'm
so mad at the way they executed it was
like chewie was on another transporter
yeah super dumb that was super tough
i agree
i mean the goonies lining up with the
dagger on the coastline stupid like
there's a lot of dumb [ __ ] in that movie
but i think it's just it's not like a
zero percent rotten tomatoes movie and
then everyone treats it as if it's like
the worst star wars movie that we need
to erase from existence i just think
that's insane i don't think it is that i
agree although
whiny boy fan petitions to like redo the
the new trilogy i'm like no there's no
there's no there's no need to do that
those movies exist and there are
certainly things that you and i both are
like wow i wish they would have done the
other thing but it's like i watched them
and was like
my eyes
oh god i i i'm no longer interested in
being in the entertainment industry
after seeing that it's like no there's
things i disagree with and there are
things that i genuinely enjoyed and they
are beautiful she does a backflip over a
tie fighter at one point like come on i
mean that was cool i thought that was
sick
me too that's what i'm saying those are
the visuals that i'm like that's awesome
i don't care i don't care if it's like a
little bit you know ham-fisted or
whatever like that's fine for me and you
know what they brought lando i think
part of being a fan of something is
accepting when episodes and installments
of movies come out that were not
good in your eyes if you're a citizen
you have to readily admit that after all
these years 33 years on the air there
are some clunkers of simpsons episodes
that doesn't take away from the amazing
ones there are whole seasons of the
simpsons that are kind of like this one
this season they kind of got on a weird
agenda and like whatever it's like that
doesn't make i know it's
apples and oranges but like it doesn't
make the show holistically a bad thing
or like it doesn't ruin the yeah yeah
exactly um so let's move on to what we
might it's gonna be you know more
controversial takes here what we think
might be overrated star wars titles you
know i think as time goes on and this is
kind of maybe a direct contradiction to
what we had just said i think force
awakens to me has become one of the most
overrated because when it came out
at all of the hype all of everybody
coming back in all of the returning
familiar faces and what we were gonna
get and even what was promised in that
movie or at least set up in that movie
not being delivered on in any way in
like the you know south park did a great
job of kind of calling out the fact that
it's basically they just remade a new
hope and i don't think that that's
necessarily fair or true but there
certainly are some close parallels you
know someone a poor you know kind of
just scavenger trying to get off of
their home planet for something greater
in the galaxy obviously but i think that
might have been intentional you know
like it might have been a i'm sure i'm
sure it was intentional like oh we're
closing a loop or we're you know they're
supposed to be bookends but
i just think as time goes on even though
i love watching that movie in terms of
the fanfare and like how people were
like star wars is back baby it's a
joyride from start to finish i watch it
and i'm like it's great i still like it
but it's not maybe the masterpiece that
i acted like on december 15 20 whatever
15 17 or whatever year it was that it
came out it's not maybe not as great as
i thought i think over time that one has
the rating has gone down for me yes and
i 100 agree with you tommy i think this
movie
the the stuff that rises skywalker was
blamed for really should be blamed on
the force awakens i think uh and the
fact that we all loved it coming out i
just think now in the years since the
force awakens you know the star wars fan
base has come to understand that this is
not
uh what they thought it was so in my
opinion at least it's now started to be
properly rated like most people a lot of
people are now like starting to to chip
away at uh its perfection which it was
not perfect um
for me i think look i you know
my star wars fandom starts with the
original trilogy so for me it will
those three films will always be at the
top of my ranking which i know a lot of
you guys asked my ranking it constantly
shifts as does my opinion of what is
currently being overrated or underrated
so if you ask me this question next year
i'll have a completely different opinion
i'm sure yeah but you should make a note
to do this again we should we should
check second weekly
are they wrong or right about certain
titles um but i think
like
people revere
and uh hold up the original trilogy on a
pedestal for all things and they judge
every new era and every new series to
the feeling of all three of those films
so much of the mandalorian was steeped
in the exact feeling of the world
building of return of the jedi of
episode six
um my
uh i'll always have a new hope and
empire strikes back as like my number
one and number two they go back and
forth in my ranking uh but usually i
will always group return to the jedi as
like number three um but
and i and i still feel that way i still
just love so many of the choices made
for that film
however i think return of the jedi and
this is gonna piss some people off i
think it just might be
more overrated than most other star wars
titles even though i think it is a great
film and i'll always watch it i will
always re-watch this movie i just think
that um
of that original trilogy i think most
people agree it might be the weakest of
the original trilogy but i think a lot
of people will overlook how much it
costs
on the uh great choices made in a new
hope and
an empire strikes back like it really
skews in some strange directions uh and
it like it gives us a great space battle
the battle of endor is incredible and i
love how it goes back
between the ground battle and the space
battle uh but i think a lot of the
dialogue i think making leia luke's
sister um
was a strange choice and um lucas claims
that that was his plan from the
beginning and i just don't buy it i
don't like that that was the first time
in star wars like
in star wars storytelling where such and
such is revealed to be related to such
and such that like felt really kind of
like uh does everyone have to be related
now can't we just be right ran into you
feel soap operate yeah yeah yeah uh and
it forced us into this weird scenario
when he did the prequels where they kind
of had to have like oh they're
they're twins and they're they have to
be separated i just
i don't know it
it felt like it closed off doors rather
than open them uh and i
so don't get me wrong i i don't this
didn't turn me off from the movie
permanently i just think that like
it was one of many
unusual choices uh and i think that
movie has like rise of skywalker has
amazing design and world building that i
will always love and i can't wait to
experience with my kids i just think
that there's just some moments where it
just skews too much into the world
building and not enough into the story
and just keeping things simple and
honest between the characters uh and we
all just overlooked that because
otherwise the movie's just so great and
again it will always be in my top three
i just think uh people say it is so much
better than the prequels and i don't
think it's that much better than the
prequels or the sequel trilogy or rebels
or clone wars or the mandalorian or boba
fett or any of these shows you know i
think i think it's about as good as the
mandalorian season one maybe definitely
better just i think that's fair i ca i
can remember uh when they re-released
theatrically
all of the original trilogy ahead of the
special editions i think it was like
they were like they gave them all i
think they each came out for like a
month one after another in our and in
rochester our local uh news
our movie reviewers this was a great
movie reviewer he he was really really
good the only thing is he was the first
he was my introduction as a kid into the
fact that comedies always get reviewed
on a harsher scale because he would give
like no comedy ever got higher than a
seven
like very rarely that i got but
so he did a new hope a new hope got a
10. empire got a 10 and then jedi got a
nine and i was like are you kidding me
yeah and then i was like oh it's my
thing it's like i don't know it was like
he was like but he was he was on top of
it he was like it's still great it's
just not as good as the first two like
you know and whatever that means so i
guess shout out to jack garner in the
rochester democratic chronicles i think
it's great for a movie to just kind of
exist in why not in in that world
hangover coasted for like four movies
and i think if disney plus existed back
then if they had an opportunity to
explore this and like a tv series with a
super high budget i'm sure george lucas
probably would have explored that back
then and he did see that experimentation
in the 80s with the ewoks movies right
like i think he wanted to
he got really interested in the world
and why wouldn't he like uh lucasfilm
was probably like we have all this great
stuff let's let's explore this world a
bit more and now just because the way
the media industry has changed they can
give like tens of millions of dollars to
produce a single episode in a six
episode series so it's just a different
world um
and look if you ask me this again next
year i will have a completely different
take on how overrated or underrated uh
return of the jedi is but i think what
tommy and i are saying is we're not like
locking in stone any definitive opinions
no we're just inviting you right now to
maybe be a little less critical of the
sequel trilogy or at least the last of
the sequel trilogy
and maybe give a more you know
scrutinizing eye to the things that you
love and maybe determine to yourself why
exactly you love them and
accept that everything that you love is
still flawed and just identify what
those flaws are and that way you'll say
well they do this other thing so well
that it makes me forgive those flaws and
that's part of why i love it
so nothing that you love is universally
great it's just
uh understand what its flaws are
that's right
um it doesn't matter that kind of nuance
is gonna go right over people's heads
and i'm gonna get yelled at on twitter i
don't really care absolutely we can't
wait
take it out on me guys i can handle it
put it on this big old bear chest look
at you you're like that uh oklahoma
state coach uh talk to me i'm a man
don't yell at me i'm the little
this beautiful little boy why are you at
him i'm a man
i'm a man
he's just a kid well that is it for this
episode of wikileaks don't forget to
check out our many great merch options
over at nurorrockstarsmerge.com follow
me at eavos follow tommy at
tommybechtold follow new rockstar
subscribe to wikileaks wherever you get
your podcasts thank you for joining us
bye-bye
you